bonsoir plus d'un million de personnes
ont accueilli jacques chirac à son
arrivée aujourd'hui à alger un succès
populaire sans précédent
cette visite d'état la première d'un
président français depuis l'indépendance
doit sceller la réconciliation entre la
france et l'algérie sur place joël
hasard le président chirac déposant une
gerbe au monument des martyrs algériens
le geste fort et symbolique de la france
à la mémoire des centaines de milliers
de morts algériens de la guerre
d'indépendance tourner la page du passé
sans oublier l'histoire
le président chirac a offert au
président bouteflika le saut que le ddt
est d'alger a remis à sa reddition au
corps expéditionnaire français en 1830
le retour de ce symbole de souveraineté
à des algériens bien dans mon esprit
sceller les retrouvailles entre nos deux
pays entre nos deux peuples
ce nouvel élan dans nos relations cette
volonté de l'algérie et de la france
d'être solidaire de se rejoindre pour
avancer sur le chemin de l'avenir
l'avenir passe par la déclaration
d'amitié signé par les deux pays et qui
scelle le renouveau entre paris et alger
ce dialogue politique sera renforcé les
investissements français en algérie
entourage et paris alger s'engage à
faciliter la circulation des
ressortissants du pays amis sur leur
propre territoire
espoir pour les harkis français de
revoir la terre de leurs ancêtres espoir
pour les algériens d'obtenir davantage
de visa des visas réclamé par bab el
oued qui accueillait cet après midi
entraînant chirac pour la deuxième fois
depuis les terribles inondations de 2001
alger la blanche a célébré comme jamais
le nouveau partenariat avec la france
une vraie fête de famille toute
l'algérie des villes et du bled étaient
représentés pour ces retrouvailles
historiques
c'est une ville en liesse qui a
accueilli le président chirac considéré
ici comme le champion du temps de la
paix dans la crise irakienne